[Music]
in egg boy news submitted by over easy
please oh yeah I like over medium but I
love poached a 17-year old has gone
viral for egging a politician oh I saw
this [ __ ] I didn't the one with that
full turn girl starts slapping the [ __ ]
out of them
I'd see this yes we got a watch this is
tight funniest videos I've ever this
makes me want to vote for this
politician immediately because he's a
real ass well you don't want to vote for
because the reason why people hate him
before this yeah is he says some stupid
ass [ __ ] from the massacre that happened
and in newsela take back everything I
just said
we apologize from this side of the
channel
what you know you know you know that you
know that like that shooting that happen
at the mosque and usually then yell yeah
that fool use it as an opportunity to
push anti-muslim propaganda and he ended
up saying does anyone still dispute the
link between Muslim immigration and
violence oh Lord
Wow it was her white guy that shot up
the that was like oh like you know white
idiot yeah he was the one that shot all
these people and killed I think it was
15 many people died including some
children - at two mosques in New Zealand
New Zealand sorry I almost said
Australia yeah and so this kid the 17
year old kid he went up to him during
like a press conference have a thing and
this awesome agree this guy's kind of
excusing the the mass shooter saying
like oh yeah if Muslims weren't you know
terrorists in the first place in doing
all this stuff it wouldn't cause so much
paranoia and these poor guys had to do
what they'd had to do like that's
basically what he's saying oh my god
yeah what a loser loser loser loser
[ __ ] loser
oh the accents are so cool though that
joke sucks he's wide awake yeah [ __ ]
sucking on his throne you gotta [ __ ]
go in here in the carotid artery yeah I
got a sinking in all the way and then
you gotta push his head down gave him a
neck support pillow like it's the
airport is [ __ ] that fools wide awake
dude the funniest thing was is that I
don't think that kid realized as he was
still recording I'll say you're getting
your ass kicked in real life like know
you're getting punched in real life
right trying to swipe the punch way
that's why they made me laugh cuz you're
still looking into the phone probably
didn't even expect to get slapped like
that well that was yuck wait but he went
pretty hard with that egg smell like
must have knowing the eggs
yeah I've been smacked on the head with
Hank so egg boy his name is his real
name is will he had gotten support from
all over the world saying like hell yeah
like thank you so much especially for
Muslims or like thank you for having our
backs and like you know that's quite an
all but that's still [ __ ] rude like
they're too rude ass people doing rude
ass things yeah they're both yeah I
don't think like that wasn't a good call
I mean people probably would disagree
with this just because it's coming from
a very emotional standpoint but what
does that do nothing no it doesn't do
anything no because we always make jokes
about it's petty it's more like ha we
got him yeah it's very what happens what
changed yeah nothing you just had to
take a bath or shower but it's like if
he well because that guy acted the way
that he did can you get in trouble now
because he ended up violently slapping a
kid yeah protest that was cuz that that
happens all the time like like people
wearing [ __ ] fur coats and you put
paint on them you ant politicians like
that [ __ ] happens like that would be
different if it was the egg was
throne but he slapped him upside the
head yeah
you slapped a minor so they did say that
they are investigating this from both
sides
what's there to investigate is a video
you got slapped beside his head you got
slapped
yeah I like that they need to get the
[ __ ] I agree I'm like what else am i
six on this shoot that's why they're
saying they're gonna investigate I guess
to see if there's any repercussions that
come after it to either party so someone
started a GoFundMe for egg boy and it
was for his legal fees and to buy more
we're trying to hold it she [ __ ]
exploded right there just do what
everybody else does and just leave in
her face a cue like literally on his
face but uh we guess so the GoFundMe
they raised as of right now $78,000 oh
that's done fifty thousand dollar goal
and they said that gold because like
because there were 50 people that they
were victims and Nelson maybe it's
because of how do you know but the weird
part about it was the kid though the
thing that takes away from it for me is
the fact that he had a recording yeah I
mean he wanted to record it was
definitely for that it was it was a
stunt and so that's the part where it
takes away from the kid a little bit if
he came up and he was like man [ __ ] this
guy but but instead as he's skating
smack in the face he's still like I
gotta record this right so if he seems
very disingenuous to me yeah you know
well maybe I'm just being a hater I
don't know but like I don't I don't know
I mean I will I would record it just for
my protection to so and in as a disguise
and then at 17 I'm trying to show my
friends after yeah exactly I did that
you get to I don't know who knows but
who's politically active active at 17
when we were young no one gave a [ __ ] I
know a lot of kids are now so that's I
kind of like that because that means
that you know they're gonna be more
involved in the future even if right now
you know they're impressionable and
whatever they're doing is all on
emotions so there's a mirror
someone painted of him oh come on really
I don't know if it's that big of a deal
this had to be it though the phone had
to be in it like he's a hero did the
world famous egg though oh my god that
would be hilarious true and then Ben
Simmons roped egg boy on his shoes who's
that
Ben Simmons he's a basketball he's won
NBA socks yeah so he's he might be like
Ozzy in the NBA or whatever or they'd
just be a regular basketball player
wearing NBA socks with no ties on sale
yeah he's an Australian professional
basketball player for Philadelphia 76ers
she's Australian playing in America yeah
it's time yeah I don't know like if it
like it feels weird like he's like I
don't know they think they're tree like
this kid like he's some kind of martyr
well that's because of what was going on
right so like here's everyone mourning
and then this [ __ ] out of nowhere
exploits that situation for his own
political game but he does it in a way
that also separates the whites from the
minorities in New Zealand so there's a
lot of people that are like we're just
trying to [ __ ] come together right
now and here's this [ __ ] doing this
why are you ruining the party right now
and he's getting publicity for it so
this is like everybody's feeling this
petty like I want to [ __ ] this guy up
here's this kid that expresses that and
he's white and he's white that which is
a big thing where it's like hey we don't
rally with these guys yeah and I think I
think that that's the whole emotional
part of it right if you look at it we're
we're also in the states to or it
doesn't mean anything to us like like
the way that it means to them so when
we're looking at it we're looking at it
from a distance and I think the when
you're in it it probably feels much
better well I'm saying it from a point
like I understand all that stuff I'm
just trying to understand like what I
feel the same way if somebody smashed an
egg upside of Trump's head and I would
have been like [ __ ] yeah I don't know
well that's you know it's not like
saying Trump it's like saying The Wizard
of the KKK mmm because if you read a
statement you'll be like this is some
fucked-up [ __ ] like why would you do
that and he's a politician there
yeah because he's based basically to sum
it up he was saying that um he was he
was he was saying Muslims commit
terrorist crimes all the time in Western
countries are they whatever and then
he's like this is the nature of them and
their religion and they are the ones
that caused the paranoia and our people
so that's why these guys are doing this
but I really think the trumpet because
he said Mexican people were a bunch of
rapists and well you gotta read this
statement - I did read this it's not the
same as Trump though at all I'm saying I
could understand the sentiment because
like but I'm trying to just relate to
that in our sense so it's like Trump has
said something similar to that about
Mexican people being rapists and thieves
and that's the reason why people are
getting raped and murdered here I think
there's a Mexican people yeah yeah so
he's doing a similar statement in that
so I'm trying to see my can you can you
see a bunch of liberals laughing and
being happy if someone puts a egg on
Trump's head well I'm sure I see from my
position if well if I would be happy if
some Allah you would yeah so I don't
know yeah that's different yeah yeah I
feel like would I be happy about it I
don't know yeah I can't see definitely
not I don't really like to dude but I
wonder if I give I would also be in that
shoe where people are cheering on that
kid in have been the Trump is what I'm
saying like what would I be also doing
that - hmm I don't think none of us
would cuz we're not that deep into other
people's an idea and in like when things
happen - I think we're all kind of jaded
because we see it so much I can also see
what David's coming from because if this
guy is as like heinous and and
scandalous as he is the egg isn't the
equivalent strike back it's like if you
got hit by a bus then it's I hit by a
bus but it's almost like this guy said
the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] in the world
and it's just a little like bird [ __ ]
yeah so to me it's not I think like for
me it would it's not as satisfying even
if I was a liberal and like let's say I
was a liberal Mexican dude and Trump
said hello [ __ ] about Mexicans and he
only got an egg hmm Oh like I wouldn't
feel satisfied but if he's suffocated on
under a tortilla then I'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you had it coming to you
that's how I feel and it's also to must
being like really desensitize now yeah
so it's like for them it's a huge thing
it is because our media blast shits
right at us like I feel like it's a big
deal but to me it's not as big as people
are making it over there maybe it's cuz
over here we get blasted with this so
much I'm just like scabbed over right
exactly
because it's like if you're looking at
it as what's the big deal then that's
why it's difficult to empathize with the
people that find it satisfying yeah
and then when you look at it as petty
that's because it's not good enough or
if a [ __ ] half can we just grab his
fake hair and pull it off or even let's
like that kid comes up and he just goes
like face to face with the dude and
starts breaking this dude down right
then it's like then it would feel I put
that [ __ ] mural up but when I see an
egg it's like you know totally so that's
I guess like a status like it's a [ __ ]
move it's not like a yeah if he really
plays like if that kid came up and he
just broke this dude down I'm like
you'll put that mural over this kid
right now you know yeah cuz I get it
it's it's in reality it's an ineffective
move but it's just satisfying to the
people that aren't right yeah cuz yeah
it doesn't translate like you know that
well you know the outcome I think that's
what it is you know so the outcome is
he's gonna stay the way he is
it might even separate them even further
now yeah he doesn't learn a lesson
he just gets humiliated so that's all it
is
[Music]